Sein Ich bin
Ich bin Cari. Du bist
Du bist Janusz. Er, Sie, Es ist
Er ist 1,75 Meter groß. Sie ist verwirrt.
Wir sind Wir sind in der Uni.
Ihr seid Ihr seid sportlich.
Sie sind Sie sind gut drauf.
Haben Ich habe
Ich habe Urlaub. Du hast
Du hast Kraft. Er, Sie, Es hat
Janusz hat Hunger. Sie hat Schluckauf.
Wir haben Also, ein Hase kommt...
Wir haben keine Zeit. - Oh Gott. Ihr habt
Ihr habt Langeweile. Sie haben
Und der Hase sagt: Plumps! Sie haben keinen Humor.
Gehen Ich gehe
Ich gehe in die Bibliothek. Du gehst
Warum gehst du immer hinter mir her? Er, Sie, Es geht
Janusz geht auf’s Klo. Sie geht mir auf die Nerven.
Wir gehen Wir gehen weg.
Ihr geht Ihr geht auf mich zu
Sie gehen Sie gehen immer zusammen.
Bei unserem Dreh hatten wir soviel Spaß, dass wir glatt die Abmoderation vergessen haben.
Aber Gott sei Dank ist uns das hier am Strand noch eingefallen.
Im Deutschen gibt es 200 unregelmäßige Verben. Und die Konjugation von diesen Verben müsst ihr
alle individuell lernen. Heute habt ihr die drei...
oder drei der häufigsten unregelmäßigen Verben
gehört und wenn ihr Lust habt jetzt noch mehr zu lernen,
dann guckt euch unbedingt mal unsere App Seedlang an.
In Seedlang könnt ihr mit interaktiven Videos lernen
und unter anderem könnt ihr dabei unregelmäßige Verben lernen,
aber auch eure Aussprache trainieren und es gibt einen Vokabeltrainer, der euch an...
in regelmäßigen Abständen an eure neuen Vokabeln erinnert. Probiert das Ganze mal aus,
wir freuen uns auf eure Kommentare. Danke für's Zuschauen und Tschüss,
bis zur nächsten Woche. Liebe Grüße aus Santa Barbara.